thank you to brilliant.org for
supporting pbs
if you're too young to remember the
launch of ride-sharing apps like uber
and lyft
let me tell you
it was
magical with just a tap of your phone a
driver would show up in minutes to take
you across town for a fraction of what a
yellow cap would charge
somehow those wizards of silicon valley
figured out how to revolutionize the
taxi industry and we all reaped the
benefits of low prices and immediate
service
things have changed in the sharing
economy since then the average price of
a ride-share trip has gone up around 40
in just the last year airbnb rentals are
about 35 percent more expensive many of
these companies point to a pandemic
related surge in demand and drop in
labor supply but even food delivery apps
like doordash which posted strong
revenues throughout the pandemic are
dramatically raising their prices as
well many experts say that what's
driving this industry-wide price hike
has less to do with the pandemic and
more with the fact that many of these
companies are finally trying to become
profitable wait i mean more profitable
nope i mean profitable period despite
being once valued at over 80 billion
dollars uber has never turned a profit
far from it in fact
[Music]
in 2020 the company lost 6.77
billion dollars and before you blame
that on kovid keep in mind that's
actually an improvement over 2019 when
they lost a whopping 8.51 billion
since its launch in 2009 uber has burned
through roughly 20 billion of investor
capital and while they are perhaps the
most extreme example they're hardly
alone
lyft doordash grubhub spotify snapchat
these are just a few of the many billion
dollar tech companies what insiders call
unicorns that have never made a profit
even airbnb which was at one time the
rare unicorn that made money has started
posting losses and this was before the
pandemic despite becoming a ubiquitous
part of our economic and cultural
landscape very few of these companies
have figured out how to
you know actually make money doing what
they do and yet investors continue to
pour money into them in fact money
losing companies that went public in
2018 actually did better on the stock
market than ones that made money this
doesn't make any sense isn't making
profits the whole point of business well
it's not unusual for a startup to
operate at a loss for some period of
time after all you have to build
infrastructure do rnd and hire employees
before you can start earning what makes
the tech sector unusual is the
staggering amount of loss investors are
willing to tolerate amazon has a lot to
do with that despite years of losing
money and years more of barely breaking
even the company was valued higher than
firms with far bigger profits it's all
about market dominance the idea is to
spend gobs of money to expand
aggressively without worrying about
profitability so that one day you'll be
the biggest player in the industry
insiders call this blitz scaling and
it's pretty popular on wall street these
days but 10 years and billions of
dollars later most of these tech
companies haven't made any tangible
progress towards profitability and it's
not clear how much longer investors
patients will last
think about it food delivery apps like
doordash and grubhub literally had a
captive customer base stuck in their
homes throughout the pandemic and still
couldn't figure out how to make that a
profitable year
some economists think that the real
problem is that many of these companies
never had a viable business plan to
begin with
transportation economist hubert horan
says that far from revolutionizing the
future of transportation uber has not
solved any of the industry's
long-standing structural problems and
that it has higher costs than every
traditional operator in every category
other than fuel they've figured out how
to shift costs like making drivers pay
for their own vehicles but that's not
really an efficiency having a million
individuals buy and maintain their own
cars is less efficient hubert argues
than buying and servicing a fleet in
bulk the company will eventually have to
make up the difference in the form of
higher wages if they want to attract
drivers so then how were they ever able
to offer such low prices because their
investors were essentially subsidizing
them new york times technology reporter
kevin bruce compares the industry's
pricing to a store that sells one dollar
bills for 75 cents sure
word of mouth will be fantastic but if
you ever want to make money you'll have
to raise your prices to say 125. and if
you think your customers will stick
around for that
good luck this is not to say that there
aren't some tech firms that are
genuinely innovating or that uber might
not someday figure out how to make taxis
more efficient but what's clear is that
many players in the sharing economy only
got where they are through artificially
low prices there's a mystical aura
around tech that makes it seem plausible
that a ride from the airport could only
cost five dollars but in reality the
only innovation was the willingness to
lose money on every transaction even
amazon isn't really performing miracles
the majority of their relatively small
profit margin comes from their web
hosting service not the retail sector so
what you might think if a bunch of rich
investors want to subsidize my
convenient lifestyle let them
i admit we certainly partook in what
journalist kara swisher called assisted
living for millennials
her words not mine
however while very few of these tech
brands have managed to achieve the
dominance of say facebook or amazon they
have acquired enough market power to put
some serious pressure on traditional
small businesses
restaurants that felt compelled to play
ball with doordash and grubhub are now
being squeezed by commissions as high as
30 percent and the taxi industry which
for years was carefully regulated to
ensure profitability and broad
socioeconomic access has been decimated
by uber's low prices which no profitable
business could ever hope to match
chillingly a recent internal document
from uber identified public
transportation as their next competitor
today as these companies start to
tighten their belts prices are going up
and maybe that's a good thing maybe a
ride from the airport should never have
cost five dollars in the first place as
kevin ruse put it getting someone to
clean your house do your laundry or
deliver your dinner should be a luxury
if there's no exploitation involved as
it strives to narrow its losses uber has
been steadily lowering its labor costs
down to below minimum wage according to
some studies and now surprise surprise
they're having trouble finding enough
drivers
perhaps their self-driving division
could pick up the slack except they sold
that off in late 2020 for a gain of 1.6
billion and it still wasn't enough to
offset their operating losses that
quarter now we're not saying you should
dump your uber stock if you happen to
have it all this may sound bad but wall
street doesn't seem to be overly
bothered by it maybe uber will someday
become the amazon of transportation that
they hope to be
but even if they don't we should be wary
about what these companies are trying to
accomplish because the end game of blitz
scaling sounds less like modern
innovation and more like old-fashioned
monopoly and the only point of having a
monopoly is to be able to squeeze your
workers and customers ideally the market
should reward companies that truly
innovate and make industries more
efficient and productive and some are
genuinely doing that but we shouldn't
let the mystique of tech distract us
from the fact that some of the biggest
players have just been buying their way
into the game
and that's our two cents
thank you to brilliant.org for
supporting pbs brilliant is an online
learning platform for stem with hands-on
interactive lessons you'll get to see
math science and computer science in a
new way through visual examples
brilliant is for curious learners both
young and old professional and
inexperienced for example there is a
course called probability statistics and
finance that can provide you with the
fundamentals so you can quantify
predictions or you can jump ahead into
statistical modeling matrices and markov
chains that are used in quantitative
finance as you learn by doing
brilliant.org will guide you through the
powerful mathematics and statistics used
to model the chaos of financial markets
click the link in the description to
learn more
to see the real world effect these
companies can have on their workers
check out this episode of future of work
a six-part docu-series we hosted for the
pbs voices channel